all right so i'm here as you can see
with the man the myth the legend
101. mary's barry's right over here to
my right yes
that also so today we're gonna be
ranking all one piece rx including wano
with attacking 101 and i think we're
gonna start right away yeah let's dive
into alabasta why not right but my first
instinct is to put alabasta in a
definitely i would agree with that like
alabasta
it's really really really good arc let's
let's put it in a i'm totally down for
that just just as wano is the
culmination of a saga that has been
going on for now like over 10 years that
was what alabasta was for the initial
major saga of the straw hats reaching
the grand line yeah
yeah no absolutely we got we got the
entire vv storyline we have the
combination of like drum island and
everything whiskey peak everything
that's been going on there uh crocodile
just still crocodile as a villain was
the first villain of one piece i mean
our long two but like luffy still beat
arlong ultimately on his first try yes
crocodile was like luffy tries crocodile
wins luffy comes back he's a little bit
more clever luffy fails again and then
finally third time's the charm and he
actually finally beats him right it was
effort yeah amazon lily we have amazon
lilly by the way that is these are all
the uh the volume covers the tankobon
covers and that is my favorite tank
cover of all time because it's like
luffy walking across the snakes and then
the boa siblings there oh my god it's so
good so
it's a very short arc and it's really
more of just the setup absolutely
meltdown and marineford are going to be
um
but we do get introduced to boa we see
luffy on his own for like the first time
since the very beginning of the story
really i'm skirting right now between c
and b
honestly i was thinking i would kind of
tend towards a bee just because the
thing i like so much about it as an arc
is
how
different it is at that point in the
story at least it felt so different from
the entire story we had gotten so far
because it was grand line like it was
islands on the grand line kind of like
luffy and the straw heads going there to
to help to liberate
this is an island that is explicitly
outside of the grand land in the calm
belt yeah and luffy goes there to
get help like he get he gets sent there
because he's not strong enough
exactly yeah later he like he's gonna
he's taken there after the war and
rayleigh comes there to take him away
and train him so
it basically is like a twist on lu on
the on the classic luffy arc for me it's
a short arc but it gets its point across
and it introduces so many plot points
and like backstory for characters i
think b is important we have now we have
some conquest hockey in there as well
let's see next one arlong park
arlon park the best ark in the east well
i don't know there might be an arcade i
like more in the east than arlon but
it's pretty much popular you know yeah
yeah yeah
i i mean i'm thinking a immediately with
this
i think arlong park is i mean there is
obviously always the bharatiya arc which
for many people is the first time they
actually really fall in love with one
piece because we have the zorro
it was with me yeah that was my moment
yeah yes but for me i think it was
actually arlon park just because
bharatiya has this epic moment which
sets up like you know zoro is like for
me my favorite character
and like the the epicness behind it but
arlong park is the first arc that hits
emotionally so deep and like
you know what i mean i mean it
it might honestly belong in s just
because of how like critical it is as a
point for new readers it it's a test if
if one piece is for you or not let's uh
the next one
if i see correctly what i think that's
the baratier
yeah that's the barracks
on
concrete
um
oh which by the way maybe you could uh
you know uh give me some information on
this i remember reading that in germany
his name was changed to don creek
that might that you know that would make
sense but i did watch one piece and read
one piece only in english so i actually
don't know
but yeah but that would make like a
german version of the four kids dub or
something
that definitely is i know for example
that luffy is roughy in german yeah yeah
but i've never watched it so maybe maybe
i would see like one or two episodes as
a kid but that's probably it yeah
but um anyway when i was a kid and i was
just watching the four kids dub which is
horrible which like you know for a much
a bunch of different reasons they remove
stuff and everything right i i still
fell in love with one piece at the
baracti arc i love the idea of like um
it's a floating restaurant the world
building there and then sanji's
character sanji before frankie was
introduced as my favorite straw hat and
i'm like yeah this i like this i really
dig this sort of setup exactly exactly
in the introduction of mihawk you can't
forget about that i was about to get
there
i would i mean i would uh give it a
i'd say a
yeah i was a or b but i think it
probably deserves an a
so just to give you a bit of background
yeah and i think i talked about this
yesterday also on stream um dressrosa
for me is kind of a love-hate
relationship because
the ad like for me the manga and the
story itself is absolutely brilliant but
it was also the point where i quit the
anime it just slogged so much through
that sometimes you'd have an episode
that only covered like nothing of the
chapter happened i'm like but let's
let's maybe go let's like tech tackle it
from the manga perspective maybe
side of things yes double flamingo is
one of the greatest villains in one
piece he once again owed his
foreshadowing skills at its finest where
we meet doflamingo way back at the
alabasta i think after crocodile was the
video we first meet him
it's like yeah we're not gonna find out
what this guy can do for ten more years
but he's always in the background like
manipulating things we always know he's
there and he's powerful we get a hint of
it at marine four but then we really see
it here and then how oda takes
doflamingo a character we've known about
for a decade and then mix him up
beautifully in law's backstory who was
like one of the most popular breakout
characters in all of one piece yup hey
yeah
yeah i mean oh no let's go with a and we
can still let's just rearrange we can
later this is not this is not set in
stone yeah absolutely oh oh i see one of
my favorite arcs actually popping up
next drum island uh drum island oh
that's a good one
we could just make these all a's and
call it a day dude
i mean there is a few i know there's
gonna be like a few arcs in there that
are definitely gonna be b or c i think a
b would be fair
i think b is fair for drum because as a
as an arc i think there's a lot packed
in there but uh as you said correctly
it's it's um
as an arc itself it's it's good but it's
not like
crazy i would say the hero look speech
alone deserves a spot in b yeah it's
like one of the most quotable parts of
one yeah you have the oh someone someone
wrote yeah you have the
uh carrying carrying nami all the way to
the top that is true that was a solid
one yeah yeah yeah yeah um next is
annie's lobby i suppose with because
that's one of my favorites also another
one of my favorite topics that's
uncovered easy
yes
that's a dif what's your thoughts on
that difficult one because i think in
retrospect it's a really great arc
because of all the contexts we have now
i would say this is an arc
that is based way more on the message
rather than the actual events with what
happens because when you think about it
from the context of the story this is
right after the straw hats had two years
of time skip they're not losing to the
new fishman pirates we all know they're
gonna kick their asses okay and they do
uh luffy has a little bit of a trouble
fighting horde but even like zoro almost
kills hordy like early on in the yard
yeah so it's like we know i think oda
realized like okay the straw hats are
gonna be able to win no problem uh with
very minimal effort i'm gonna make this
about the story about the world building
about the discrimination and the racism
that pretty much exists in the one-piece
world all about the fishman and the
merfolk and in that part it shines
beautifully
um yeah it's it's kind of it's a little
bit so we're gonna get to that later on
it's a little bit like thrill of bark
for me where in retrospect it gets a lot
better because of the context we get
but in the moment it was not the
strongest because also for hodie jones
it kind of at the end it makes sense
obviously where oda was going with it he
was kind of like showing how
discrimination can lead different people
on different paths right
but
it he was he could have been stronger as
an antagonist in the moment i felt
personally beer see i'm gonna say it
before i die again
yeah i would say let's go with a c maybe
for that one because i would say it's
like at the moment it was slightly
like it was not as cohesive in the
moment at least as was fishman island
amazon lilly
yeah i think that's fair yeah still like
good especially in retrospect the great
arc but
yeah in the moment it felt kind of weird
um
it was like also a hard a hard arc to
pull off properly just because it was
after the time skip and you wanted to
show off
how strong the straw heads were but at
the same time present like the super
dark
uh like concept of racism with the
fishman so difficult to pull off
it's a little bit difficult but i think
oda i think oda did a good job of it i
think so as well next hopefully it stays
that way impel down oh [ __ ] my favorite
arc is it i would put this it is yeah i
would put this in s but i understand
it's probably not a lot of people's
favorites so
i a or would a or b or whatever but um
this is my favorite i love a good like
prison break story and this is when i
first started reading one piece weekly
and the return of all the old baroque
works characters and the introduction of
ivankov who was one of my favorite
characters in the story um i just like
uh it's going to come out sometime this
week or next week like a
video on bonclay on mr2 that i've been
working on
uh and i i revisited like a bunch of of
impul down and obviously also alabaster
but yeah it's
it's so good the entire dante's inferno
it's it's so i i love the inferno and
it's a great it it's great parallel to
that buddhist hell as well like there's
different levels to that s or a that's a
good question let's put it in s for now
because it was really good i respect
that and then we'll we'll we can still
fine-tune the s later
absolutely
oh is that uh
okay
it's just yes
um okay so
very much like amazon lily we have a
setup arc more than anything i would
give it a b honestly just because it's
very important and i love the bellamy
scene i love the blackbeard speech
that punch dude was just earth shaking
dude the bar scene fantastic but i i
would say it's since it's mostly set up
for skype blackbeard's introduction yeah
i would say b plus from my perspective
but you feel free to direct me up or
down i think b i think b plus is fair
because yeah and then just like it's
like it's a companion like a sister arc
with skype i would say
yeah
let's see next one ooh is um oh oh
there's a nice little not a very long
arc uh might actually be the shortest
arc in the story it might be because
romance dawn was like five chapters this
is like two or three it is not long
quite important though we get the entire
crocus roger thing set up um
basically the the tutorial uh chapters
for the great brand because the straw
hats had no idea how to navigate it
thank god crocus told them because
otherwise they would probably have died
let's let's go with b um
sounds good yeah that's that's reverie
okay
so um
uh
this is basically info dump the arc
that's basically what this is still like
up to this day i'm like what what's your
thoughts on this like the entire eem
thing i'm like why did you set up so
much new stuff like a ruler of the world
if you want to wrap up
be like 400 pictures for all we know um
eem is i like to think eem is some sort
of immortal from the void century
whether that mean like
eem is literally immortal just cannot
die or eem is like a ghost yeah like
you're something like that like i like
to think that they originated from the
void century they're like 900 years old
in some capacity yeah like a i think is
as good it's decent definitely
yeah a is yeah i think for this arc
pretty much yeah then
what we got there is dory and braggy so
that's
little guy so little garden yeah little
garden that's a that's a nice little arc
um okay i'm gonna say c for little
garden before i cut out again yeah
that's i feel like that sounds fair just
because it was like a fun arc it did set
up a bunch of stuff but um yeah i would
also say was not like
the yeah not in yeah not super integral
for the entire you know like compared to
the other arcs i mean it's just yeah oh
another really interesting one loketown
next uh yeah i'd say a for log town
definitely okay with that
nice yes let's drop that in here
oh next one is the
the infamous
the infamous argument
[Music]
okay here's the thing yeah i don't hate
this arc and what it's set up i just
hate foxy as a villain
um
if this was a character that was
introduced in east blue that luffy
fought against i don't think i would
have worried about it too much because
it's like weaker but it's like dude
luffy just punched out a damn god in the
last arc okay and now we're dealing with
this guy i guess you could look at it as
like an innocent little arc in between
after like like oh we had a skype which
was super epic now it's something a
little bit more normal um
i think i mean i think i think most
people figure that this arc is setting
something up for the end with the davey
backfight and you know like davy jones
and davey jones locker it's kind of
something that
seems to be important and you know you
have all the straw hats who are like no
like this is goofy what we're doing
right now but this fight is actually
legit it's it's gonna get big in a big
way later on yeah but it doesn't change
the fact that it's the one arc like i
always tell people don't skip anything
with one piece everything will be
important but ah you can kind of yeah
this is the one arc where i'm like you
could probably skip this i i would put d
yeah okay cool
maureen ford
oh boy isn't it yeah i think i said it's
like i said those like arcs at the
beginning were like the most critical
points and this was the time skip but
also whitebeard we find out how we find
out the raw power of a yonko not even
like the strongest yonko a weakened
yonko has this much power and this is
what we're going to be fighting in the
new world so
yeah
next one
oh speaking of buggy uh we have orange
town if i had to pick the weakest ark in
the east blue i would probably pick one
so i'll pop let's pop davey back down to
e we're getting into post any lobby or
water 7 2 or whatever you want to call
it um
now here's the thing when it comes to
these post arcs that like follow like a
little star not just like the two
chapters in between an arc but like oda
actually taking the dedicated time
this is probably the most important one
out of all of them oh that's yeah yeah
that's it that's actually i would give
that an a even though it's really short
like having yeah
do we get the
sky splits
and then like yeah uh
i think it's fair to put that in a i
like i said like the post war arc is
really important too but this i think is
like we get enough lore dropped and also
like like luffy's family oh in the sunny
we get the sunny and the mary's funeral
if you want to include it in that maybe
it's uh maybe it's yeah well well no
here's the thing i i would include the
mary's funeral as the last chapter of
vinnie's lobby as the captain
i would say yeah so i would go this is
after that so yeah i would say a let's
do it and if we exclude if yeah if we
put the the mary into anna's
lobby then it's a
yeah yeah yeah um so next next is the
post-war arc yeah this is luffy kids
yeah luffy's kid backstory
that's really good it's really really so
you know what i didn't really care for
that at the beginning when i first read
it
all those years yeah and the only reason
that was because i was impatient and we
just had this big war
and i was just like all right i want to
see what happens after the war i want to
see where the straw hats are i want to
see what's going on with this um and
they're like just focusing on the past
with luffy but looking i've reread it
many times and i've like do newfound
appreciation of it okay
irby yeah we'll give it a
kid luffy and getting that entire
backstory for our main hero let's ah
i'll say that's a big one
it's a big one but let's give it a b um
okay what's next uh punk hazard
punk hazard okay um first proper arc of
the new world law shows backup who was
like the most popular character
introduced at the the supernovas so
um
it was one of the weaker ones definitely
it was it might have been i would
i think this is comfortably fit in b
maybe a c
i'd say c let's put it in c yeah yeah
there's so many other moments in the
story that basically get trump it's a
lot of great it's set up but it's not
like as memorable i would say
yeah
all right that's next uh return to saba
odi i believe that is ah
see this is a really good moment for
nostalgia for me i would say it goes
into b
but yeah i would go with b if you want
to go with a because for nostalgia value
for me it's so cool i'm good with b next
one um
if i see that correctly
so
it has to be that evening
big mommy i mean kinda yeah sort of
um
so now honestly i'd stick with s i mean
it kicked off the entire damn story i
mean like i think it's a disservice to
the manga to say that like yeah the
first dark is it's whatever it's it's
good but it's not the best i'm like it's
pretty important
you know sava odie
oh that was a video now i don't think
it's quite as very close but i think a
yeah
yeah
uh
what's this one oh skype
that's
okay
so for a long time even kinda still now
um
it's not one of my favorites like as a
standalone thing without the context we
have i would probably give it a b
yeah me too
um okay let's go next kudos is
um
okay if i was gonna say orange town was
the weakest ark in east blue i'd say
this takes second place it's the second
i would give it a d as well
um oh thriller bark is next okay good oh
that is a that's a very difficult one
yeah
what's your thoughts the highest i could
see putting it up was the a i don't
think it's the s-rank arc um
i love
the i love horror i love like uh slasher
movies from the 80s you know and
everything like that like friday the
13th nightmare on elm street i love that
kind of stuff i like zombie movies so
i'm very much feeling the vibe and the
aesthetic of this arc um moria as a
villain he has a really powerful fruit
that he uses in a really unique way
him as a character though
not that interesting yeah kind of
annoying um
but
i liked pirona yeah i liked uh i liked
ryuma was amazing
as a villain here four shots yeah one
wanna was brought up here and it is not
referenced forever or is this brought up
here also wonderful in a way i guess i
think an a for i mean
i did a list once i did a poll on my
fans could vote on the best moment of
one piece period and that nothing
happened moment was number one it was
like it was not even close it was far
and away you know it is
oh next one
oh yeah here we go the big one what's
your thoughts
okay it did have a roachee let's start
with that you know it's like okay
uh no no no i mean like
it isn't technically over yet
um we got two more chapters and then
we're going on oda's break do you think
though like let me just ask you i find
it very hard to believe that
we're leaving wano in two chapters
i don't see oda doing that i i yeah i
mean i'd like to see maybe a very short
act for that's kind of like the epilogue
of one where we get like 10 i i feel
like 10 chapters for me would feel like
a decent amount of chapters to wrap
everything up that we see so we see like
this country starting to rebuild a
little bit and we get the celebration we
get maybe a closure for zorro
all that kind of stuff i don't know i
feel like i also
i don't think and i don't think i
wouldn't say oda is rushing necessarily
i'm just like he just got done with this
huge ass battle
and he does want to take a break i mean
the dude deserves a break after this and
he might just play like all right i'm
gonna wrap up wano in like two more
chapters i want to make it as nice as a
bow as i can possibly manage you know
there are going to be questions but you
can answer those later we can always do
a flashback later to wano if we have to
you know
like yeah
like let's say we don't do the ryu
mazoro thing right now in the next two
chapters so let's say you know a few
chapters later in the next arc maybe
zoro has a flashback too if you there if
you could pick
i i assume you would also like to see a
bit more of one all right not just oh of
course of course wanna though in terms
of placement s like yeah absolutely it's
my favorite art yeah it definitely took
my place i like it took that's fair that
is fair it did take uh over
uh water seven and this lobby for me
i i don't make those decisions right
away i wait to see how it sits and how
it like you know like maybe probably by
this time next year yeah i'll i was like
all right now it's been a year since
wanna we'll get a good idea but i s
absolutely right now yeah next one okay
so next dark we can move on from
spoilers now water seven frankie
i'm putting it today but what do you
think yeah i mean for me and slobby
water seven i kind of treat them as like
one arc honestly personally um but if if
we splitting it i'd say a but it's so
good
oh uh whiskey peak
at the time like if you were just at
whiskey peak i would say like oh yeah
uh you know orange town was like a d
you know whiskey peak though this is
like an a right now but like compared to
where we've gone from the story yeah
that's yeah i put it on um absolutely
i love the way it's i love the way it's
set up i love the way it's like an
island series that is animated through
big mom's abilities um that she
completely controls it's the first time
we get the true power and influence of a
yonko
um and how powerful yonko is and oda
does not shortchange her you know like
you know luffy like punches her and wins
no it's not how it goes it's not he's
not good enough yet he just barely like
is good enough to beat or
even that is like kind of questionable
like to be the first commander
like gets a good power i mean honestly
honestly um i mean luffy as he is now is
a different story but as he was then i
think luffy should have lost that fight
yeah i mean and i think i think katakuri
definitely like my personal opinion is
that katakuri did
at some point just decide to train luffy
yeah he he he's an honorable he's an
honorable dude he got to a point in the
fight where it's like okay we've been
fighting for like 12 hours at this point
i kind of respect who you are and what
you're coming from here okay i would not
only say that kind of i think luffy
literally liberated katakuri and like
showed him that he can be himself he
doesn't have to hide he can like embrace
his scars and embrace eating donuts and
everything and he can fall on his back
like luffy allowed katakuri to be
himself i really want katakuri just to
say screw his family and then just leave
the crew and just you know be like you
know what you guys have treated me like
[ __ ] for the most part like i'm not even
allowed to show you my face without you
all laughing at me so dude honestly
screw off i'm out of here yeah i deserve
better than this i've got to join the
straw hats that would be like that would
break i had a theory about that for a
while not even so much that but like
luffy has a fruit that's very similar to
katakuri's so
yes we're still streaming we're still
good so i would say okay a for whole
cake island um yeah yeah yeah i would go
with a for whole cake island yeah nice
and then the last one is zoe
i'm glad at least it didn't go out like
when we first started holy [ __ ] that
would have sucked yeah that would have
sucked so bad okay but so i'd say b is
good
are you happy with that to your list as
we have it but yeah i think that looks
pretty good for me so we'll just go with
hot land in there nice
that seems fine with me um i think davey
back is on the bottom as it as it
deserves to be
um
orangetown
syrup village yeah those are probably
the d rank yeah this works good for me
yeah and i think the s here also arlong
park we have marine fort and slobby
uh impul down
the first chat like romance dawn and
mono i think that sounds really fair
i think that's cool well thanks so much
for joining me tekken i hope thank you
sorry for the compliment
complimentations at the end there you
guys at all it happens that's great all
right thanks for joining us thank you
see you have a good day bye bye um yeah
so uh that's our tier list i hope you uh
you probably have a lot of thoughts you
agree and disagree with if you want to
watch another video you can do that
right here as well